our national security analyst irish era
meshram joins me now from Houston in
Texas thanks so much i'm speaking to us
this morning now one US official
described the events is one of the most
aggressive acts in recent history would
you make of it all you know it's at the
very least it's unprofessional it's
dangerous and it's unsafe it's putting
both Russian and American troops in
danger what if the Russian pilot lost
his or her focus and hit the bridge of
that ship what if the American captain
of that vessel lost is cool and
correctly assumed that to be a
provocative attack posture from those
two Russian su-24 attack fighters any of
those combos could lead to disaster so
dangerous very unprofessional and
perhaps provocative I am not sure if
Russian pilots or their regional command
in the Baltic which is right next door
it's Moscow's backyard would decide to
carry out such an aggressive move about
20 flyovers 11 of which very close to
the bridge of USS Donald cook without
pre-approval from the Kremlin without
pre-approval from the Defense Ministry
in Moscow so very provocative very
unprofessional and very unsafe and that
is exactly why I back in the 1970s the
United States and back then the Soviet
Union reached an agreement to prevent
these Close Encounters to make sure that
these unsafe incidents will not occur
but unfortunately and this is a lot to
say but unfortunately back then the
Soviet Union had a lot less to prove and
was a lot less insecure than today's you
know Putin's Russia is well that leads
me to my next question why do you think
Russia Russia carried out this this
simulated attack the Russians have
always considered Ukraine and the
Baltics the backyard and they ever since
Estonia Lithuania and Latvia those three
affluent at baltic countries former
soviet but during the Baltics join nato
russia was always against that you know
it
you we have had a whole host of Russian
incursions to sort of a quasi occupation
of eastern Ukraine by Russian forces and
russian-backed militia Russia has also
had multiple flyovers not just in the
Baltics but even close to the United
Kingdom sort of going against RAF Royal
Air Force pilots but they should know
this they do not want to direct
confrontation with the United States and
the United States does not want to
escalate this Russian equipment is very
old Russian pilots don't get the same
training that American and NATO pilots
get you really don't want to put the
American f-18 Hornets or the American
f-16s force falcons put to the test you
really don't want to do well it's been
established Russia has been aggressive
they've indeed him broken quite a few
broken a law in this respect but what
can be done about this what can America
do so far we haven't heard much from the
Kremlin White House press secretary came
out and and condemned the incident we
know that the US Navy has condemned the
incident but there is so much we can do
on the on the one hand yes we can shoot
down Russian pilots and Russian aircraft
just like turkey did when Russia
violated its airspace while bombing
Syrians in northern Syria if we do that
that's going to be an escalation we're
talking about international waters not
over US territory so that is sort of the
distinguishing factor between what
turkey did to that Russian bomber
Russian sort of fighter bomber and what
Russians are doing that over
international waters but this is again a
clear provocative moves so to escalate
things is going to make things much
worse but again Russia these are not
actions of a secure country these are
not actions of a leader and his military
forces that feel secure in their own
backyard at home and also regionally and
globally Irish Irish can speak to our
summer form of Texas thank you very much